*slow creaky steps*
*JUMPSCARE*
Hello everybody,
my name is Markiplier and welcome back
to the Joy of Creation.
This time it's the halloween edition.
And this time it features...
I-I'm assuming that it's gonna be "Ignited Springtrap".
Just in time for the 'spoopiest' of halloweens.
So let's get into the adventure...
Of the Joy of Creation once more.
Hi!
Oh hi! :D
Man: Uh...hello?
Sinister Spoopy Phone Guy: Hello there...
I see you're in quite the trouble...
Man: Who is this?
Sinister Spoopy Phone Guy: Who I am is not the problem...
No, the problem is that you're currently in a cat-and-mouse game.
Man: What? What are you-
Sinister Spoopy Phone Guy: Listen closely...
The complex you're currently in,
is like an anchor to the dead...
While it still remains standing,
it keeps enraged spirits inside it...
You have to destroy the complex.
Man: And... how would I do that?
Sinister Spoopy Phone Guy: Find and destroy the weakened pipes around the place.
Try using a blunt weapon such as a hammer to break the pipes open.
The flammable gas will be released,
then get back to the entrance of the building,
and light it up. With a lighter...
Markimoo: But bu-
Sinister Spoopy Phone Guy: Oh... and before I forget to mention it...
You're not alone in there...
And he doesn't like uh...
*clears throat*
visitors.
Mark: Yeah. Man: Who?
Sinister Spoopy Phone Guy: Who he is is not the issue.
What he will do to you if he catches you.
If you just happen to run into him,
don't run or shine your light at him.
Hide as fast as you can,
and either wait for him to pass by.
Or distract him by playing a sound through a camera speaker with your phone.
Man: W-wouldn't I kill myself by blowing this place up? Wha- Who is "he" and how do you know all this?!
*watch Mark's face*
Sinister Spoopy Phone Guy: Oh lets just say:
I have some, uh...
history with the place.
Man: What does that-
*sigh* Dammit
Mark: Oh okay.
So Springtrap's stalking through here, this is the place from Five Nights At Freddy's 3.
And I gotta make s- Oh I saw him on the camera.
I dunno where that is!
I don't know where "I" am!
I dont know where any of this is in relation
to anything that I'm doing here so "I AM LOST."
Like a little baby in the woods!
*scared voice* Hello?
Is that one of those weakened pipes that I need to bash with a hammer?
I gotta find a hammer!
Oh shit this is gonna be a...
Bitch...
*balloon boy laugh from phone*
Ah, that's familiar ._.
*scared voice again* Hello?
Is anybody home?
Am I alone here?
*Exclamatory noise* OH
A hammer!
YAY!
OKAY!
I gotta acquire a lighter too-
Why didn't I get any of this shit on the way in?!
WHY AM I HERE?!
Who se-
*suddenly terrified* Who sent me here?
Oh Jeez. Oh Jeez.
Okay, so I gotta don't shine light,
Hide,
and then-
*wide face of terror*
*scared panting*
(Wierd noises for a while).
Wabooski!
*clang* Habooshki.
*Pleased noise* Hmm.
Breathing in that good old
natural gas... (LOOK OUT MARK!).
*step step step step step*  HEY -FUCK YOU FUCK!
*EXHALE* Alright, sorry; lost my composure there.
That was not that bad.
Okay, so I'm willing to bet,
that the hammer was not in the same place that it was before. -_-
And I'm just gonna be...
stuck wandering like an idiot, aren't I?
God damn it.
I didn't even see him coming so I didn't know he was gonna be-
running down the hallway.
Oh man. I mean I did "hear" him
and stupidly I didn't try to do anything to prevent my own DEATH,
which is my own fault I suppose.
Okay, yeah; it's not there.
It's not even replaced by the lighter or something.
* phone click* Okay, so let me see if I can find him.
*click*
On the cameras...
*sharp inhale* Woa-uh! I found him on the cameras! *click, followed by balloon boy laugh*
I dunno where that is! Ooh hey...
Oh that's weird...
Oh that's super weird...
Oh that's super weird. It made him change directions though
which is kind of an important detail to remember here.
But I don't know where that is in relation to anything; or I am.
Okay.
Alright, so I gotta be on the lookout for a hammer.
*creeped out noise*
Ooh! *Click*
Can't make a sound.
It's still playing a sound
it's not- that's not right.
That's not right it says 'playing sound'
I'm not done-
Balloon Bitch: Uh Ha Ha Ha.
*realizing...* (Good job, Mark)
*Springtrap running in the distance closer*
That's this hall isn't it-
AH! FUCKING!
*singing* Fucking Fuck You.
Fuck you.
:-(
Fuck you. Alright.
Okay, that didn't work out so well!
But maybe this time it's gonna be better!
(Whatever you say, Mark, whatever you say).
Maybe this time I've got hope!
(Or do you?).
I don't think I do! But maybe this time I do. :-)
So the hammer's back in this spot again so I got the hammer.
Okay so now I just gotta break the pipes.
*clank*
I hear someone laughing in the distance over there...
I don't like that very much.
*clicks phone* *nervous noise* Where is he? *click*
Okay. *click* So the long hall.
Is def-
HEY!!!!!
I DIDN'T MEAN TO! GOD DAMN IT! MY INSTINCT IS TO RUN AWAY!
*scared noises* *springtrap growling*
*very scared noises*
How am I still alive?
I've no god damn idea.
*Mark thinks he's safe and slows down*
*clicks phone* *Impending death*
*weird noises*
*screams*
*screams* GOD RUN!
RUN!! *screams again* Ah...
Fuck you. >:-[
Fuck you! *Angry mark is angry*
Aargh! This is the 'wrong' way-
HI!
Well I'm boned...
*Thunk* *Thud* *Jumpscare*
My face-hole.
Ok, so I'm gonna do a very stupid experiment.
I'm gonna do what he said, and I'm just gonna.
*unsure of himself*
I'm just gonna stand here!
(Best experiment 2016!).
If he comes by and I'm not dead
then I know I know how to do something.
So that's good I guess.
I suppose. Oh shit he's coming.
Oh he's-  OH HEY.
You comin' round that corner- OH HEY!
OH HEY!
Hi! *death*
*stutters and stammers* OH GOD!
I-I-I didn't-
AM I NOT SUPPOSED TO LOOK AT HIM?
Aw man that's-
That's no good!
That's no bueno. (Good in Spanish)
Thats no bueno at all!
That experiment (2016) failed! Horribly!
*clang*
WOAH WOAH WOAH WOAH!
Woah. (X3).
Woah, Speedy!
Woah! Slow your roll there, buddyboo!
Speedy bunny in a hurry!
(I think he didn't know this but that rhymes).
*monkey noise*
(Magic lighter of all hopes)
I didn't even see that!
But I got the lighter!
Okay, that's good!
I didn't even know where the lighter was.
But I picked it up because I randomly pressed a button!
Okay that's good.
I like random chance!
*sarcasm* Random chance is my favorite thing in games!
Oh-OH.
OH.
OH! I'm back in the main office! :D
Oh hey- OH Hey!
Okay, so this is exactly a replica of...
The main area!
*mutters* Shit where's he?
Dammit.
The office outside, that's where I was: Hallway Bonnie,
Arcade Room
something or other.
I don't see him anywhere...
Where is he?
Ooh Foxy Room.
Is there a hammer in here?
Oh shit.
*balloon boy laughter*
*footsteps*
*faster footsteps*
AH! COME ON! WHAT AM I SUPPOSED TO DO?
Did I accidentally  play a sound in the exact same room that I was?
Was that arcade 2 or was that?
Did I do bad there? I think I might've done bad-
(Another death).
(Or not?). (Wierd noises).
(Even more weird noises).
Apparently I run faster backwards! Holy shit.
AHHHHH!!
Well I'm dead.
*Singing Bohemian Rhapsody*
THUNDERBOLT OF LIGHTNING!
VERY VERY FRIGHTENING ME!
*melodically* HOLY SHIT.
Holy fuck. I'm dead, I'm dead.
*sassy* Hey, there's a sound going on in the arcade room.
You wanna go for that?
*Growling*
...
I didn't actually play a sound you stupid idiot...
OH GOD I'M DEAD!
AH FUCKERINO!
Hey, Fuck you. Hey, hey fuck off.
*jumpscare* Fuck off!
Okay.
*clang*
*clang* Two! *singing* I got two, I got two.
I got two, okay.
So I got two.
OCH- *footsteps*
*muffled* The song of a...
FUCKING BITCH!
OH COME ON!
NOOOOO!!
Don't, don't, don't do nothing.
Please
please leave me.
Leave me be.
Oh Jeez. (X1).
Oh Jeez. (X2).
Oh Jeez. (X3).
Oh Jeez. (x4).
I think I got away,
which is amazing by itself.
*clang*
Alright, I dunno how the fuck...
I got away.
I dunno.
I've no idea *clang*
OH! Ok, he's over there. Alright, that's good.
So he's far away from me.
He's pretty much on the opposite end,
of the doodad.
so there's one right here...
Punk! *clang*
Okay, and then I believe...
I'll just wander around here...
Oh Jeez.
*constantly mutters no*
Oh God no.
*footsteps*
*scared Mark*
*hopeful?* Question Mark?
*click*
*click* *balloon boy laugh*
*relieved* Oh my God, Oh my God.
I don't know how I survived that.
*tired exhale* I don't know why I'm trying to.
You know, stay quiet about this,
But uh...
I've been skirting death REAL CLOSE HERE.
Oh my God. *clang*
*whispers Oh my God over and over*
Oh. Oh Jeez
*mutters Oh Jeez over and over*
*shouts Oh Jeez over and over*
YES!
YES!!
YES!!!
YES!!!!!
Yes! >:) *lighter being struck*
Light it up! Light it up bitch! Light it ALL-
*dick move*
What the fuck?!
[The game glitched from saying 5/6 instead of 6/6]
WHAT?
[ Sorry mark :( ]
WHA-? ARE YOU KIDDING ME?!
What the fuck happened?!
DID I NOT DO IT?
WHAT THE FUCK WAS THAT?
WAS THERE NO END TO IT?
WHAT THE FUCK!?
I just did it!
I JUST DID IT!
Okay, I'm pretty sure I did it.
Like, I'm pretty sure I did it.
I got the requirements, I got the hammer,
I got the lighter.
I'm pretty sure that's just scripted to be like:
*pretentiously* YOU CAN NEVER ESCAPE.
OOAAAGRRGG!
I'MA GET YOU!
And then, you know, that's done.
So I'm pretty sure I did it. So that was...
The Joy of Creation: Halloween Edition.
I like it: it's good; more concise in the story.
More explanation in what you're supposed to do
and more purpose in the objectives; which I think is a very good thing.
So, let me know what you think down in the comments below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
The final demo will be available, like, tomorrow or something;
so you'll be able to play it for yourself very soon.
So, thanks again!
And as always, I will see you...
In the next video!
Bye - Bye! :-D
Subtitles Edited By TheSamiGamer (and others) and republished by his alt account: lostwithoutyouie.